Superkomputer klasik terbaik kita makin berkuasa,
dan kita makin mahir dalam pengkomputeran, termasuk simulasi sistem.
Tapi mensimulasikan alam semula jadi ni memang masalah yang susah secara umumnya.
Nama saya Victoria Lipinska dan hari ni kita akan terokai salah satu algoritma
yang boleh buat simulasi alam semula jadi menjadi mungkin pada komputer kuantum.
Jom kita mulakan dengan contoh dan tengok kafein.
Ia adalah molekul yang mudah.
Untuk mewakili konfigurasi tenaga hanya satu molekul kafein,
kita perlukan lebih kurang sepuluh kepada kuasa 48 bit.
Iaitu sepuluh dengan 48 sifar
dan ia lebih kurang 10% daripada jumlah atom di bumi.
Dan sebenarnya ia makin teruk lagi.
Kalau kau ada 125 orbital dan nak simpan semua konfigurasi yang mungkin,
kau perlukan lebih banyak memori
dalam komputer klasik kau daripada jumlah atom dalam alam semesta.
Itu mustahil nak diwakili dengan superkomputer.
Tapi ada harapan untuk komputer kuantum,
sebab ia memang secara semula jadinya bagus untuk mensimulasikan alam.
Untuk molekul kafein, itu bermakna mewakili
sistem itu menggunakan 160 qubit.
Kedengarannya lebih mudah diurus.
Pelbagai algoritma kuantum telah dicadangkan yang membolehkan
komputer kuantum yang lebih kecil mensimulasikan alam secara heuristik.
Masuk: variational quantum eigensolver atau VQE.
VQE adalah algoritma yang berjalan sebahagiannya pada komputer kuantum
dan sebahagiannya pada komputer klasik.
Ia membolehkan kita mencari nilai yang menyelesaikan masalah pengoptimuman tertentu.
VQE sangat berkait rapat dengan kaedah lain yang melibatkan
variasi parameter seperti quantum approximate optimization algorithm.
Mengenal pasti aplikasi VQE dalam industri atau penyelidikan kau
memang macam satu seni, tapi ada panduan kasarnya.
Secara umumnya, VQE boleh digunakan untuk masalah yang boleh dirangka
sebagai masalah pengoptimuman dengan pemboleh ubah berterusan.
Ini adalah kes, contohnya, dalam banyak bidang kimia kuantum.
Seringkali, dalam kimia, kita berminat dengan keadaan asas.
Keadaan asas ialah keadaan tenaga terendah sistem itu.
Untuk mencari tenaga keadaan asas, VQE meneroka
tenaga untuk konfigurasi sistem yang berbeza
dan mencari konfigurasi tenaga yang paling rendah.
Secara ringkasnya, VQE menerima huraian sistem kuantum
dan mencari tenaga yang paling rendah.
Ia buat ni dengan mengubah konfigurasi sistem.
Untuk mulakan, kita kena masukkan huraian sistem yang sesuai
yang difahami oleh komputer kuantum dan satu set parameter yang menghuraikannya
yang akan dioptimumkan.
Bahagian kuantum bagi
algoritma ini menyediakan sistem dalam satu keadaan
yang dihuraikan oleh set parameter tertentu dan mengira tenaganya.
Manakala bahagian klasik pula bertanggungjawab
untuk mengoptimumkan parameter tersebut pada setiap langkah.
Proses kuantum-klasik ini diulang
sehingga kita mencapai tenaga terendah.
Jom kita zum masuk tengok apa yang berlaku di sebalik tabir.
Konfigurasi tenaga biasanya dihuraikan dalam Hamiltonian
dan biasanya ia adalah matriks yang sangat besar.
Dalam algebra, untuk mencari eigenvalue terendah matriks
yang sepadan dengan tenaga terendah sistem,
kita cuma buat penguraian nilai singular.
Tapi, matriks yang kita tengok ni saiznya sangat besar secara eksponen
dan ia adalah masalah yang amat sukar secara eksponen untuk diselesaikan secara algebra.
Hamiltonian ini kena diwakili dalam bentuk
yang boleh difahami oleh komputer kuantum.
Jadi diterjemahkan dari bahasa kimia ke bahasa pengkomputeran kuantum.
Tak payah risau pasal butiran tu.
Pada akhirnya ada cara yang boleh diprogramkan untuk menterjemahkan Hamiltonian yang biasa
dilihat dalam kimia kepada Hamiltonian yang boleh difahami oleh komputer kuantum.
Kita kemudian masukkan
Hamiltonian ini bersama circuit, yang kita panggil variational form.
Memilih variational form ni macam satu seni jugak.
Sekali lagi,
ia mewakili teka-teki terbaik kita tentang apa keadaan kuantum sistem itu mungkin.
Variational circuit ini diparameterkan dengan satu set parameter theta,
dan kita juga masukkan pilihan awal parameter-parameter ini.
Berdasarkan ini, bahagian kuantum VQE:
menyediakan keadaan rujukan, contohnya, keadaan sifar;
menggunakan parameterized quantum circuit, iaitu variational form, untuk menyediakan keadaan kuantum
bagi tekaan awal parameter pada komputer kuantum; dan ia menganggarkan
tenaga yang sepadan dengan keadaan yang dinilai melalui Hamiltonian.
Anggaran tenaga ini kemudian dihantar
ke dalam classical optimizer, yang mencari set parameter baru.
Parameter tersebut dikembalikan semula ke quantum solver,
dan keseluruhan proses diulang.
Komputer kuantum mencari anggaran tenaga baru, dan
classical optimizer mencari set parameter baru, dan seterusnya.
Kita ulang proses ini sehingga penyelesaiannya menumpu.
Maksudnya sehingga perbezaan antara hasil setiap langkah cukup kecil
mengikut keperluan kita.
Pada akhirnya, algoritma mengembalikan tenaga yang telah diminimumkan itu.
Okay, ini bagus.
Tapi mungkin kau tertanya-tanya macam mana kita tahu ini betul-betul berkesan
dan kita tak akan terjumpa tenaga yang lebih rendah dari yang kita cari tu?
Soalan yang bagus tu.
Rupa-rupanya kita tak pernah boleh menganggarkan tenaga yang lebih rendah daripada itu.
Ini berkat sesuatu yang kita panggil prinsip variasi.
Prinsip variasi menyatakan bahawa had bawah terbesar
bagi tenaga sistem itu sentiasa merupakan
tenaga terendahnya yang sepadan dengan keadaan asas itu.
Ini bermakna tenaga yang dinilai pada mana-mana keadaan lain sistem itu
akan sentiasa lebih besar daripada tenaga terendah.
Oleh itu, dengan VQE kita tak pernah akan dapat sesuatu
yang lebih rendah daripada tenaga keadaan asas.
Tapi, kita memang boleh menumpu ke sesuatu
yang lebih besar daripada minimum yang kita cari.
Ini kadang-kadang dipanggil penyelesaian metastabil
dan ia adalah cabaran yang para penyelidik cuba selesaikan setiap hari.
VQE berguna sebab ia menggunakan circuit yang lebih cetek
berbanding protokol lain yang membolehkan kita menganggarkan tenaga keadaan asas.
Ini menjadikannya sesuai untuk perkakasan kuantum jangka masa terdekat.
Dalam video ni, kita dapat sekilas pandang apa yang VQE boleh buat dan macam mana ia dibina.
Tapi saya galakkan kau terokai Qiskit dalam konteks ini.
Walaupun kita masih di peringkat awal perjalanan kuantum kita,
mungkin kau dah boleh jumpa ia berguna untuk masalah yang kau cuba selesaikan.
Nama saya Victoria Lipinska dan ini adalah gambaran keseluruhan
tentang algoritma variational quantum eigensolver.